was richard feynman a liar he invented  quantum electrodynamics created feynman  diagrams predicted nanotechnology and  quantum computing he solved the riddle  of the challenger explosion and won the  nobel prize but in his memoir surely  you're joking mr feynman he relates a  story i think i got three patents i  don't know what they are anymore three  patents have my name on it there's no  record of a single patent let alone  three was the old nobel laureate just  mistaken even great minds as sound as  his warned us the first principle is you  should not fool yourself and you are the  easiest person to fool great geniuses  can make great mistakes so you be the  judge did feynman forget  did he fool himself  or was richard feynman a liar